[Música]
the american dream es not dead y h
meek américa quien paga
let's make emery craig
en los años 80s ryan utilizó esta frase
en su campaña política
en los 1990 es el presidente del cual
utilizó esta frase
en discursos políticos y más
recientemente ya saben quién
de american dream vamos a ver
quien cree que el sueño americano es
generar riqueza digan yo
vamos adelante a ver otra vez quién cree
que el sueño americano es generar
riqueza
bien quien cree que el sueño americano
es libertad
es crear deuda para generar mis sueños
[Música]
y quien cree que el sueño americano no
existe es solamente un sueño
buenos días yo soy vidal espinoza
soy segunda generación de tijuanenses
soy contador público por profesión pero
empresario entrepreneur por convicción
en 1998 comencé mi caminar como
profesionista
siendo contador
en septiembre 11 del 2001 me desperté en
la mañana con todos los acontecimientos
que pasaban como contador público pero
esa noche me fui a la cama como
restaurantero y esa historia duró más de
siete años
en el 2007
a mí me secuestran
pierdo todo pierdo mis negocios pierdo
mis ahorros gracias a mi familia
recupero mi libertad recupero mi vida
vuelvo a nacer quien puede decir que
tiene 22 fechas de nacimiento
y en el 2009 me tomo un par de años
sabáticos disque haciendo eventos y
banquetes
me voy a radicar a la ciudad de san
diego por tranquilidad y confort
cuando uno se da cuenta que toca a fondo
sólo uno sabe que ha tocado fondo nadie
te va a decir hey way
ya toca este fondo ahora chingar le no
pues no no pasa si yo les puedo decir
que soy el ejemplo del sueño americano
cuando a mí me pasa lo que me pasa el
2007 yo decía dentro de mi sabes qué
voy a salir de esto pero si voy a perder
mi dinero en negocios de muchas cosas
algo que no perdí fue mi cerebro y mis
ganas de vivir
el sueño americano
sin saberlo los padres fundadores de los
estados unidos de norteamérica lo
mencionan dentro de la constitución
política del el decreto de la
independencia pero en 1630 john winthrop
que fue gobernador de massachusetts lo
dice por primera vez en uno de sus
discursos políticos
dice él que es un sueño
de la sociedad donde todos trabajando en
conjunto y siguiendo la biblia podían
alcanzar sus metas
thomas jefferson en 1776 en la de la
independencia de los estados unidos de
norteamérica sin saberlo repito dice que
todo americano mientras no sea esclavo
tenía el derecho a la vida a la libertad
ya la búsqueda de la felicidad
después nos vamos al siglo 19 game
américa es una tierra de oportunidades
sin precedentes donde quien llegará ahí
podía lograr
todos sus sueños sueña en grande
en el siglo 20 si se está dando a
conocer de forma más general a través de
libros revistas escritos que la gente
que migra al oeste y la gente que viene
desde europa logra sus objetivos como
tener su casa un mejor trabajo llegar a
generar riqueza aquí podemos ver una
gráfica del sueño americano a través de
las generaciones es muy importante
conocer lo de las generaciones
el sueño americano en la época moderna
es única y exclusivamente característico
de los eeuu de norteamérica
los ideales de democracia de derecho de
libertad oportunidad e igualdad
la libertad la definen como la
oportunidad de prosperar y llegar al
éxito
esto quieren que sea generacional que lo
podamos traspasar y migrar de generación
tras generación
en esta gráfica podemos ver que en la
actualidad desde el 2011 el sueño
americano para muchos era tener un
retiro confortable
pero si nos regresamos a esta gráfica
podemos ver que la generación millennial
si quieren que el sueño americano sea
una experiencia
a libertad personal
ahora
yo les voy a dar mis 6 puntos para
elaborar el sueño americano
les voy a dar un mapa una guía muy
sencilla aquí está
ver la gráfica
la sencillísima
no voy a hablar de seis puntos
éxito
el primer punto es el primer paso
responsabilidad
nosotros somos los propios constructores
de nuestra vida nosotros hacemos el
guión nosotros lo dirigimos y nosotros
lo actuamos pero ser responsable de tus
actos
yo me topo con clientes donde llegan y
me dicen oye que hago que no puedo hacer
yo les digo que hacer está en ellos si
toman o no toman esa decisión sin
embargo ellos quieren tomar lo que yo
les digo porque si sale mal a quién le
van a echar la culpa a mí o ellos van a
ser responsables
a mí me van a echar la culpa a mí me van
a responsabilizar de esa decisión
ok los tu destino está creado por las
decisiones que tomas
el segundo paso es todo depende de ti
está en ti solo en ti hacer que tus
sueños se cumplan
sueña en grande
sueña más allá de lo que está soñando
el tercer paso no juegues seguro no seas
conformista
piensa fuera de la caja estamos a dos
milímetros de conseguir algo distinto a
los demás dos milímetros si un
futbolista le pega al balón dos
milímetros de distancia de forma
equivocada no va a entrar la portería
pero si le pega exactamente en esos dos
milímetros va a lograr el el gol
el cuarto punto no dependas no dependas
de nadie
si pero no significa que no te vas que
aislar que vas a olvidarte de los demás
la gente de éxito deja
escritos la gente de éxito deja este
puntos donde tú puedes tomarlos y te
apoyas para que llegues al éxito
paso número 5 cree en ti solo en ti tú
eres tu propio creador aquí hay una
frase que me gusta mucho de tony robbins
joker ins activa muy interesante este
día en la mañana todos los días le hablo
me llama para saludarla y me dice hijo
cómo estás
digo yo bien ama este voy rumbo a
tijuana me dice ya estás preparado luego
pues la verdad no y voy nervioso
como típica mamá mexicana me contestó no
pues mejor ni te pares porque la vas a
regar
qué nos dicen en la casa hijito a ver te
vas a ir a la escuela
vas a cursar una carrera universitaria
para que te vas a trabajar nunca o la
mayoría de nuestros mamás no nos dicen
oye vas a cursar una carrera
universitaria para que seas empresario
para que seas emprendedor para que hagas
lo que tú quieras no no no está muy
difícil eso que hacienda se te va a
meter contigo que la miscelánea fiscal
sin saber que la miscelánea fiscal se va
a afectar que estaba el libre comercio
se va a cancelar te va a costar más
impuestos pues no es cierto no saben
solamente hablan
yo carente de percepción cambia esa
mentalidad cambia ese chip si nosotros
tenemos la posibilidad de cambiar lo que
hacemos en nuestro día nosotros tenemos
la posibilidad de escribir nuestro guión
positivo o negativamente
esta mañana que decía yo sé es que tú si
a lo mejor no estoy preparado a lo mejor
si estoy preparado pero pues cuántos
podemos decir que estamos en el club de
speakers de terex pocos si cambio mi
mentalidad y digo sabes que pues soy de
speaker y la plática fue una porquería
pero por lo menos soy tan explicarlo
paso número 6 el ego
y luego es lo peor que tenemos ok
nosotros mismos somos los que
desarrollamos nuestro éxito yo lo sé
todo yo puedo todo que no me diga a
nadie lo que tengo que hacer porque yo
sé lo que hacía en mis restaurantes yo
sé lo que hago en mi despacho yo sé todo
no es cierto no es cierto hoy la mañana
el universo demandó señales estás
preparado platicaba con él el güey de
starbucks y mesa es que esté yo
corro yo soy corredor
y dije ah caray dice todos empezamos
nuestro desarrollo infantil caminando
correcto
pero en cuanto sabemos caminar o
coordinar los pies nuestros movimientos
que hacemos corremos y los que tenemos
tienen hijos van a decir sabes qué
posición tengo que estar atrás del
chiquillo porque camina y corre
todos en nuestros en nuestras vidas
queremos correr
una vez que aprendemos a caminar rápido
tranquilos todos todos la gente de éxito
tiene mentores tiene coaches no dependes
de ti mismo de tu ego pero son mis seis
pasos y voy a terminar con una frase de
una de las personas que más admiro
ciones en este mundo es walt disney y
booking green you can you get o wish
remember that the hall of fame western
vaya mouse de american dream es nadie
jat gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]